daaamn au début du film est
en fuite, il a évidemment choisi un
endroit sans extradition mais vous avez l'
impression que quelque chose ne va pas
c'est 100 millions de dollars hein
ce n'était pas si difficile de vous trouver Toretto
se cachait
Dom est sur le point de  être frappé par
des informations qui changent la vie J'ai besoin de votre
aide Dom va au DOM ce n'est pas seulement le
dernier recours mais c'est le meilleur recours
que j'ai poursuivi cette équipe de
chauffeurs hautement coordonnés quatre continents dans
12 pays
les emplois les plus récents diplômés  les à un
tout autre niveau
tu vas m'aider à attraper une équipe
responsable maintenant pourquoi est-ce que cela a été
pris il y a une semaine
il joue avec ta tête
Letty est mort Dom j'ai besoin de savoir avec certitude
alors je vais avec toi vivre sous le
radar fuyant la loi c'est
tout le monde une opportunité de faire les
choses bien attrapez les loups vous avez besoin de
loups
Je pensais que le Brésil était notre dernier travail alors maintenant
nous travaillons pour le faucon
vous pensez étrange il a besoin d'une équipe comme
nous il a besoin du chameau  des éons à venir
avec leur cible de compétences spécialisées
Owen Shaw ancien major du
soldat SAS SpecOps
Je vous offre une chance de reconstituer votre
famille vous nous aidez à vous
laisser vous aider à partir et vous nous accordez
des pardons complets tout autour  c'est
l'affaire, prenez soin de plus tard,
Hobbs n'a vraiment pas d'autre choix,
surtout s'il veut sortir de la
loi, j'avais un chien, ils sont les
seuls capables d'attraper ce gars mais
Owen Shaw n'a jamais été attrapé, il
n'est même jamais entré dans un  court c'est un
résultat nous n'avons pas affaire à des flics trafiquants de
drogue c'est certainement l'une des
fois où une équipe peut avoir rencontré son match
nous avons parlé d'une guerre de véhicules ce n'est
pas ce que nous faisons beaucoup plus d'un jeu du
chat et de la souris  entre nos gars et
le gang de Shaw, vous croyez aux fantômes, elle
ne sait pas qui diable il est.
Letty a cette amnésie, il sait donc
qu'il peut jouer à des jeux d'esprit avec tout le monde
parce qu'elle fait partie de mon équipe
.  ne
tournez pas votre  retour sur la famille même quand ils le
font la plus grande faiblesse est sa loyauté
alors que je ne me soucie pas
de l'un de mes mr.  : vous vivez par une question de famille,
cela vous rend prévisible
et cela signifie que je peux vous tendre la main et
vous briser quand je veux et Shaw
exploite rapidement tout, en particulier l'
idée de famille de quelqu'un, je suis prêt à partir à tout moment et
quand je vais, je sais quoi  c'est pour